hello everyone i am the case
for those who already know me i
am with the pleasure of speaking with
el assam jean-degros room hello
samantha is that what are you in korea
at the moment where i am still living
and of course south korea france
north korea now it's a bit
problematic living there did
i hear there were problems
between north korea and
south korea do you  think the situation
is dangerous you think it's good
it's been a long time since the
situation has been a little tense one of them we're managing
the situation has been quite tense
recently it's sure that she has
rhetoric with a little more
serious if we want but no I'm afraid I do
n't sink for the situation
so people who speak French
and who hear that they hear us
that already that it comes to me
from canada today we are going to talk about
metropolitan French we  va france we
must speak the french of france and
also the  canadian french which is
quebecois we are going to talk about the differences
between the two versions of french
so first of all i wanted to
ask you if in canada canada is a
bilingual country or quebec is
a bilingual region where that  has changed
what is happening
now in canada and quebec
it is a very good question so
officially obviously from canada it is
a bilingual french-english country
however the only province that speaks
really fluent french in
most places it's the province of
quebec
so i think i was looking at
the stats recently in 2001 only 8
for 1 3% the quebec population
was mother tongue english so
offered two of about 85% 80 90  % are
really native French is
also people who are there from other
countries and then
but French is still fairly widely spoken
in other provinces,
for example in Acadie the province of
New Brunswick French  I speak it
quite fluently and then in Ontario and
also several French communities
we can do and then some small
French-speaking French-speaking communities
also in other provinces
but in general French really
more concentrated in Quebec in the
province of Quebec then also good in
Acadia  and then a few
francophone communities in ontario
so there is a bit of everything what
is the situation in what is the
situation in montreal because i know
that i have a cousin who avoids june in montreal
but also a friend who lives in
Montreal he told me that the situation
could change for the last 20
years I don't know if he's right in the
sense that now there are a lot of
people who speak a language but there are
also people who only speak
French or  only English so if you
enter a bar respect you have you
ordered in that she in fact I
start thinking her of all the stuff
do you see people who are a little
confused at  because of that so yes
montreal is the only region in the
province of quebec that is truly
bilingual so almost half french
half english there are some neighborhoods
that are strictly english some
neighborhoods that are strictly more or
less french then with neighborhoods that
are printed  changing serve so it's
always the most terrible it's hard
to know is what good do we have
customer networks in French or in
English or only a genre in a store
how does it work but
usually for example - my language
kindergarten is French
but hey that's how I'm more they
took advantage of it speaking in English I
'm losing my French I'm not going to speak
French more than 5 in May for example
if I'm in Montreal I'll go to
a bar or in  a restaurant
probably that I will order French
because it went badly in kindergarten
and then most of the people out of
all the passers-by who work in a
service in the  Norman service industry
they are going to be
talking about them and I was wondering for
example can you choose between
1.10 and French the English index also
compulsory to study which for
example Canada in French because of the
law 5 and the chair of French language
primary education and I think
secondary education also a certain
level must be in French so it's
not easy to have an indication in
English even if everything is an immigrant
who writes in Quebec
but concerning the university its choices
and to all then for example in montreal
but which is a university which possible
one but I think that it is all the same in
english as that this teaches and the
several good establishments in these
super words oc which are  only in
english photo in montreal
but outside of montreal it's
really hard to find actions
and schools that broke in english
so me when i was little i lived
in quebec city
i'm so  u know there was a high
school that was in english
the actress reese in english or one or
two high schools in life so
but most
in most cases it's
really fun because in fact of all  way
you are you are surrounded
by English even if in Montreal we speak
French but it's crazy people of
course an interview where it was said
that 40 years ago the situation was a
little different
we actually spoke more English  only
French but now it's bilingual
so I think you hear the right one in
any case you still live and therefore you have
the trenches but if you go to live
in Quebec in Montreal early nothing heard
for English which tends even on
television  television, for example, there
are the gives by relaying the programs
in English there were these missions in
French I imagine most
French people but yes exactly it is very
easy to have access to the immaterial world
of English is developing like television  the
music  ue who also
american culture culture have immigrated finished
everything but in general again
by hordes of montreal but it would take
a quick response response tomorrow
i know most people
are not check up so most
people  apart from moria especially the
older generations their brake
their english and the loans been at the level
the younger generation because
for some time the part of
the primary school
the younger generations the younger
they start to learn french
so  if generation there their level
of English sorry is a little
better than before but it remains all the
same that a general the Quebecers by
mutual aid and certain cultures certain
nationalism which means that the Quebecers
do not even have to  speaking English
really well appears therefore as in
you think that there is an internal political attitude
to finally protect
French because anyway  So
of English it's a dominant language
so I think for example in France
there is an institution for the protection
of French rony but I think that
's the same problem that creates a lot
I think it's not  a problem
but anyway in catalonia
for example in spain we tend to
keep catalan because it is a
language because spanish is dominant
so there are always people in fact
not understanding each other two years ago
this discussion when I was in
barcelona argued all the time
on Catalan Espanyol and that in the
system in general we prefer to speak
Catalan and
Spanish both I say it finally it is important
to keep no because if we speak  not
we no longer speak to after in balance the
gamer momentum that makes people sing like people
is it true that the french
that is spoken in canada now is
similar to the french that was
spoken 2 3 300 years ago in france  i do
n't know because i was not v  ide
not tender either but that's what they say
I think that from what I've
seen according to historians it's
actually quite the body so the
prince and Quebecois and more similar
to the French
18th  or 19th century I thought 18th
century that easy for france is no
longer there network this because the french
who colonized new france which
was the name of quebec the 4,100 years the
french who came to new
france
they have they are  came near, however, the
region of the island of france which was the
paris region also the region of the
northwest provinces and then when the
settlers arrived in new france
the language they could communicate with
each other at the tricolor was really
the  dialect of the isle of france the
second act to nothing and then over the
years the english eventually
arrived in new france at the
start of the internal wars of link
between england and more of france
and then with the tra  city ​​of paris who is
who was signed if the call well it was in
1763 so the treaty of paris it is
really there that new france
cut all ties with metropolitan france
and then from that moment good  the
french new france of francis
quebec has really evolved by part be
my mission so from 1763
it's really there that a station a
dissociation or your saber between the
two the dedicated to action since
french quebec really evolved by
his name and then a good bit
later contact with France but if I
think that's one of the reasons why
Quebec French is currently
approaching much more
required French which is 300 years old